hello my name is Mike mecosta and I'm
going to tell you a little bit about you
know what was being done in our lab
about improving the robustness and
reproducibility of quantitative
proteomics it's definitely an area that
we've been working a lot on and it's
something that stuffing on a solved
problem and its work in progress I think
we're definitely getting there and I'll
tell you a little bit about how we're
doing this and what current state of the
art is and where we still need to go so
if you look at pretty much how pretty
omics has been done classically it's
this methodology methodology noted as
shotgun proteomics and basically what we
do is we take a very complicated protein
mixture was subjected to some pretty
office and then we get these peptides or
smaller portions of proteins out which
have a much less diverse physicochemical
properties then and the intact proteins
you separate them based on some sort of
chromatography most most traditionally
micro-cap arielle see we're at each
point in time we collect a mass spectrum
so on the x axis as master charge and
abundance so we basically have a three
dimensional piece of data and we tell
the instrument or the instrument makes
decisions on the fly using a process we
call data and an acquisition where we
select individual signals that are
coming off the column and subject them
to tandem mass spectrometry or ms ms so
we perform multiple stages of this and
then we repeat the cycle over and over
again modern instruments are getting
extremely fast so we can now collect
data to run about 20 Hertz or 20 m sms
spectra a second that's particularly
powerful I'm something that hardware
wise this is this has been an enormous
feat of engineering to overcome and form
okay so why do we want these
fragmentation data so we look at this
data we put the mass spectrum in
multiple m sms spectra and we have this
individual peptide sequence and we have
an MSM spectrum for this peptide
sequence
we'd get a spectrum that looks like this
and the reason why it's valuable is
because for an individual peptide
sequence the we have two sets of ions
form between each individual amino acid
so for instance here and the difference
between two adjacent amino acids is the
mass of that side chain of the amino
acid so for instance if you look between
this bond break of lucid and
phenylalanine we get two different sets
of ions and one would be this 467 which
contains the n-terminus the other one
just 792 is contains a carboxy terminus
and so on and so forth you look
different between the Sistine leucine we
have a mask fragment that's you know 384
353 which contains the in terminus and
not a file which contains the
carboxy-terminal so we can use this as a
unique signature of the peptide sequence
or we can just look at the differences
between mass masses to know that that
this difference here is given rise to
basically a leucine amino acid back in
1994 Jimmy and John Yates us 20 years
ago now came up with an incredible
invention which would led to the
development of a software tool called
seaquest we basically take these MSM
spectra in a protein sequence database
and you take the spectrum which has a
given precursor mass using a precursor
mass go through all possible
combinations of amino acids that would
add up to and given sequence masked with
some tolerance he then from that amino
acid sequence entering a theoretical
spectrum based on the predicted fragment
I instrument carboxy terminus and the
amino terminus and then he would try to
match the two together and calculate a
score and the primary spore that was
originally done was a supporter known as
the cross-correlation scorn and this
match is what we often call a peptide
spectrum match and then we use this to
identify individual peptides so we can
use an approach by where we take intact
proteins digesting the peptides and then
we have these peptides we subject them
to fragmentation spectra and then we can
map these fragmentation Specter back to
protein sequence is printed predicted by
a genome to identify the determining
identity of peptides are coming off hplc
home now there are some challenges with
this immense well I'll talk about for
the rest of the talk and the main thing
is that these mixtures are very
complicated so if you're to look at this
data like such and make a plot just to
the MS cans there are in each of these
little black dots in this slide is
literally a peptide that's coming up the
column big blood versus time and
abundance and intensity is being done in
a grayscale that's kind of coming out of
the screen so there are hundreds if not
thousands of individual peptides left
column and if you actually look at this
a slightly different way you can we now
know that we can we can detect between
100,000 and 200,000 peptide features and
then lcms run this is a lot so a lot of
data that's coming off in a very short
period of time and most of our runs are
between one and two hours and so being
able to make a mass spectrometer that
can actually select and acquire data for
a hundred thousand and 200,000 peptides
they're coming off the chromatographic
timescale store a a daunting challenge
so just to kind of look at this a
different way if you took a slice
through the data like so you can pick
plot the cross-section through this data
so this is signals here's retention time
on the x-axis and tensing the y-axis for
things at 850 so things that a single
mass-to-charge they're usually hundreds
if not thousands of things at the same
mass and you can actually also put it
the other way we take a slice their data
like such an this is what we call a a
mass spectrum so it's as a master charge
on the x-axis and abundance on the
y-axis and now there are hundreds if not
thousands of things at each in each
spectrum in each point in time so again
some modern instruments run at 20 Hertz
20 m sms by for a second I've already
told you that we can collect we can see
in a short period of time between 100
and 200 thousand peptides in a run
but these instruments can only collect
data on the speed of about sixty to
seventy two thousand spydra per hour so
we're not we're still never going to be
able to catch up with not in the near
future to this sampling everything is
coming off on a chromatographic news
deal and again I want to further
emphasize that this is kind of a strange
way of doing this because what we do is
as we see things coming off the column
we're focusing our time and our energy
and the most intense Mutko species
coming out to call them first and then
we work our way down to the least
attempt ones later on and run to be a
sense of how crazy this is and I guess
this is the way our field in doing this
for 20 foot of plus years is imagine
going and visiting a foreign city so
i'll give us an example I see like Kyoto
in Japan and let's say you were told you
can only visit and explore the city by
visiting the tallest buildings and
tallest structures first so you go to
Kyoto you go to the tallest building
into some sort of office building or
hotel structure and and you look inside
of it it looked very similar to a lot of
western cities a lot of American or
European cities and you maybe look
around and to look you know looks very
similar there's no difference there's a
phone of a television etc you look out
the window and you see you know all the
cities you know its surrounded by hills
um let's have this high-speed train it's
a little different don't have many of
those United States you look and see
while they drive on the left hand side
of the road but in general things don't
look that different from a lot of other
cities that are in the United States or
or Western Europe so if you so you miss
a lot of really spectacular things about
missing Kyoto in this things like you
know the temples and the shrines and he
and the storefronts and and here's
another shrine and and it missed missed
the people and the different types of
you wouldn't experience anything about
the cultural of food you would just take
you a long time in order to even get
down
street level to begin to see these
things and of course the stuff that that
street level is really what makes a city
a very spectacular place so so if you
wouldn't learn much about kyoto by going
to the tallest structure first why would
you use this approach to understand
protein mixtures and this is basically
the question that our lab has been
trying to address for about the last 10
years our methods have largely been used
based around using using this data
independent acquisition where we focus
collecting data on the most intense
struck tech features first and then we
will slowly go down to lower lower but
ones ones even though instruments have
been getting faster we make it down the
street level occasionally we still spend
a majority of our instrument time
collecting data on the most intense
features what is the general strategy
that we should take or we generally use
with your no foreign city when we
generally do well often we build on
other people know are you doing by a
guide book or you know you look in
google and you do a google search you
say okay Kyoto places to visit and and
in there you're already starting off at
a much better place then starting the
tall structures first which is a very
arbitrary decisions start at power
structures and go down to lower
structures and while it may not pick up
all the best things are the most
important things of going and visiting a
foreign city it's definitely going to be
much better and much worth your time
then starting randomly and just going to
the taller structures so that's
basically what we end up doing now is
we're advocating to people that you
start with things knowledge about a
given sample and disease type we know a
lot about biology already and thus
starts go and ask very hypothesis-driven
questions suppose to starting off just
trying to fish and try to find things by
hoping that the most intense building to
provide you a a sense of the city then
again you know you can look at things
like go to food so you certain kind of
food or cultural things I should
experience wrong nothing there
another example of why this isn't very
useful when I started the lab now about
11 years ago we had made a decision that
we're going to see elegance to the model
in vivo system for for developing
technologies a lot of reasons why we
wanted to do this but some of the main
reasons were it was the only multi so
organism of the genome that was sequence
complete this time and what I mean by
completeness meeting all chromosomes
tailored telomere to telomere or
sequence without any gaps whatsoever it
was a it was a huge tour de force and a
major monumental effort in order to make
sure that it was truly sequence to
completeness and it was also the only
organisms which we knew the complete
lineage for all the 959 somatic cells so
worth john sulston received the nobel
prize for this work so if you're trying
to understand a system to completeness
one of the things that we obviously are
missing stolen alice is information
about the protein expression approaching
abundances within the system we already
know the genome to completeness which
was unusual and it still is unusual to
have a genome sequence completeness we
also knew a lot about how this genome
encoded for different different lineage
but how this cheatham gives rifle living
functional organism like worm is still
something we had very little knowledge
about so we started off by using this
also as a model system for insulin
signaling and of course there's obvious
reasons for that but the pathway the
insulin silly pathway is highly
conserved so if you're looking at humans
the insulin receptor is including my
gaff to and katherine karnazes are
included by age 1 and p decays or PK and
and the fox hole kent transcription
factors are coated by dash 16 so there's
a lot of by my understanding and
characterizing the only pathway in
purdue mix using proteomic technologies
we felt like could help us inform some
information about starting the same
pathway interviews so we've decided that
we would just take a brute-force
approach we're pretty good protein
biochemist so we're going to
fractionated proteins that were and with
the attempt to improve our chances of
identifying these proteins
mixture we're trying to improve our
identification using a independent
acquisition and what I mean by mud pits
here's we took reverse-phase the intact
proteins and then we digest in the
peptides and ran ten multi-dimensional
chromatography separations a separate
peptides we did separated by some charge
in the eighth fractions and then
digested those and measure them by the
peptides and then we also tried to
separate the insoluble proteins by
tendency subjugation and manage those
this each of these mud pinch these LC LC
runs we're taking 24 hours so this is
about 30 days of mass spectrometer time
just for one sample but again we were
kind of ambitious we felt like we could
we could work really hard and we be able
to solve these problems the big thing
that we weren't expecting at all was
that after collecting all this data
which is a ton of data about six million
in misamis SPECT releases on older
technology identifying these number of
proteins identified zero proteins that
were known to be wrong it's 1 igf-1
singling methylene so again so we were
basically we hadn't made it down the
street level yet we were we were just
sampling the most intense features that
were were in the organism was at 10 6 or
7 thousand proteins and a lot of the
proteins that were interesting to us and
trying to understand this is biochemical
pathway where things that we weren't
even being characterized for one of our
biggest challenges so so the methodology
was kind of locked in we were on with
everybody was collecting data in this
way and in many ways you basically have
to take step backward before you can go
forward so we began to make some
decisions and saying that okay well we
actually think it's this data dependent
acquisition that's starting from the top
the most intense structuring going down
on the most intense peptides working
down is what's causing our biggest
challenges and it's also creates data
that's kind of semi-random its ear
reproducible and we you know we can say
stuff about what we detect but we can't
waste say anything about we're not
detecting and it's again we really
struggled to do much of any type of
quantitative analysis which of course
what we were really interested in
I began to think us guess thinking about
what we're now calling or the field nail
calls targeted proteomics we were using
nano flow liquid chromatography such a
reaction monitoring mass spectrometry
and this is a little bit different
instead of trying to now sample
everything that's at a mixture what we
wanted to do is start with a hypothesis
we want to basically do that Google
search first or looking at travel guide
first and start with these are the these
are the most important proteins for us
to be able to measure and then be able
to target specifically measure those and
ideally would be able to do this for
hundreds of proteins in parallel that's
where we began to get started so we use
different type of mass spectrometer
calling triple quadrupole where we
basically start with peptide sequences
we tell the quad to measure individual
peptides we've subjective inclusions and
then we measure fragments in a in the
second filter called q3 and it becomes
them very a very selective filter so
basically you want to measure this
peptide we would measure that and a
series of fragments and then you have
this chromatogram versus time which is
only reflective of signals from that
precursor mass of those fragment I'd
miss those becomes a fairly unique
signature and we began to think of these
things that's kind of a a mass spec
western blot and the fact that these Co
Barry Wirth's time means that we
actually have encoded most of these
information of this sequence backbone
and so not only are we getting a
quantitative measure their signal
intensity but we're also getting a lot
of qualitative confirmation that we
actually are measured what we think
we're measuring and so to go back to the
data that we're looking at before
remember we were looking at the dash 16
with the folk a transcription factor
akt1 was a searing 3-kinase the insulin
signaling pathway and previously we
weren't able to detect them even with 30
days of mass spectrometry time but now
that we have a targeted measurement we
can use a synthetic peptide standards
and we can now confirm in less than 25
minutes of instrument time that we can
actually detect and determine the
identities of these individual peptides
and we can have some for basic
quantitative measure plan for
development versus condition
etc this is pretty exciting to us this
was a pretty much a game changer we now
knew that if we had we have there's no
shortage of hypotheses we just now need
to be able to go and rapidly test these
hypotheses without having to generate
antibodies for each individual target
protein the other thing that's a pretty
powerful miss is that the quantitative
linearity is is pretty much unmatched by
any other analytical technology so if
you're looking at this individual
peptide from this protease protein is
spiked in the human plasma and we made a
dilution curve and if you blowing up the
bottom end of this delusion curler it's
still linear blowing up again it comes
up curve a little bit but still
extremely linear but basically we have
quantitative linearity for four orders
of magnitude four logs and modern
instruments now can be one with five
logs and the sensitivity is down to the
mid to low animal level depending on the
peptide so here's a case where this is
12 animals that peptide and column and
10 micrograms one fraction you even
plasma and we're able to still detect it
and these other Peaks on the side it's
sort of like an antibody western blot
that's big done it very low but it says
you're we going to get some from lack of
specificity when you're trying to push
the limits of sensitivity but still this
isn't the bottom end of what we detected
okay so I've sort of told you a little
bit about the positive things that in
2006 when we start to do these
experiments we struggled with the
software there was no way easily start
to make the tell the instrument to
measure specific peptides for protein or
which mass is for the individual peptide
we had while we could do that manually I
took a lot of effort so we couldn't
generate methods we couldn't really look
at the data and we definitely struggled
with being able to do is between
instrument platforms each vendor sort of
had their own tools it was very hard to
look the same data between different
platforms so at that point in time I
began to we hired a software engineer we
built the software tool called
when losses and really eye-opening to me
this project them we started this vision
between friend and McClain and I that
bumper manager with a couple key
attributes that we felt like really need
to be in the software tool what is that
we wanted to be protein pept eccentric
most software tools that point in time
or what i would call Nass centric so the
mass spectrometer you tell them at
summer and measure certain masses but we
didn't want to MIT measure no mass 652
and 933 we wanted to measure this gene
product with this peptide etc with this
fragment I'd other tools that were out
there were other command line based so
they weren't that user-friendly where
they were used as like a web browser
type interface and now also was an ideal
because we wanted something that was
sitting on the instrument platform we
wanted the ability to to do full undo
because if you're setting up a method to
measure a specific set of peptides he
could actually imagine wearing at the
point where you have a very large list
of peptides hundred or a thousand
peptides and then you accidentally
delete a peptide or transition and then
you want to make it easy to be able to
go back and add them in if you realize
it was a mistake so this is something
that was wasn't is appreciated that much
scientifically but as far as
engineering-wise was a was a Norma's
challenge and we're still probably
between academic and also commercial
tools or the only tool of this type that
actually implements full-on do breeding
support this is an open-source academic
project we so were lots of different
tired view of targeted proteomics has
changed so we originally talked about
SRM lahum but we've also expanded this
to work out some more modern analysis
strategies to and aren't just specific
to triple quadrupole mass spectrometer
that i have already pointed out there's
been a lot of talk within our field
about front of standards standard
formats they tend to be a little
cumbersome they're not as efficient it
has a render file formats also there's a
lawson lost in translation loss of
information that's lost as you go from
the medical Mantua to a standard format
so we want to make sure that we could
read the vendor data directly without
without file conversion and that was
actually quite a bureaucratic hurdle to
overcome because the vendors weren't at
the initial time trying to make it easy
for us to get data out of their out of
their their software we want it to be
free and open source free because we
wanted to do this as a service the
community open source because we wanted
just make it completely available to
people to check our code to make sure
that we were doing what we were saying
we're doing and we want to develop
professionally and what I mean by
professionally is is not just that it
was developed by true software engineers
we wanted it to be to use very
professional software development
practices as far as testing those code
reviews even the way we support the
software as far as a support board and
returning and responding to comments and
criticisms and providing feedback and
fixing bugs we wanted this to be a tool
that was truly supported and not
something that was just developed for a
project and then forgotten about so one
of the first things we did was the began
to look at this data and one things I'd
point out forehand is there was no real
tools for looking at these things across
bender types this is the one of the
first time I started to display the data
so get it from mandi voltages lab at the
fred hutch cancer research here at the
seattle which was enough ap science
instrument and we had dated from our lab
and we were able to plot it for the
first time this is the data from the key
trap in the state of mortal quad
instrument and you can notice that there
are some slight differences in the data
we were able to look now for the first
time ever at the same same different
peptides between different instrument
platforms were able to use the same
signal processing tools to be able to
get quantity of data from both of them
this was really a game changer and
and it was was shocking to us that that
known anthems of Memphis earlier now and
in the last six years or so that we've
been working on this project we released
the first version in june 2009 at the
American Society for mass spectrometry
meeting and to be honest we were really
shocked when we had hit over 100
installations in a month now are
routinely at the amount of 6,800
installations per month and all in all
we've had over 30,000 horrible Skyland
installation so this is definitely
wasn't was it was a huge need within our
field and stuff just that people are
downloading it people are also using it
so every time the software is booted up
on someone's computer it pings our
server to see if there's a new version
and we just count those things we hit in
this last week or so we had first time
ever 11,000 startups or boot ups turn
pro meetings this was something that's
again this is definitely a being used a
lot and we can also check to make sure
that people are using different than
newest versions etc okay so I talked a
little bit about we built software but
you need to measure this one individual
gene product or its individual protein
how do you decide which peptides want to
measure for this target analysis it's
not a simple problem so a lot of other
labs have started to say what we should
use a lot of our DD a discovery data for
this and and so but these repositories
that people have been building I like
hanging out list is one of the super
systems biology and if you look at a
protein like a bow a one which is a very
important protein in in HDL for
high-density lipoprotein me a good
cholesterol look at the data with an
empty doubtless it pretty good it's a
doll of peptides that are shown in red
are the ones that people are found
previously in other experiments you
notice that the ones are missing are
actually from the signal peptides is
good that they're not present in
pinellas and and we can rank them based
on those things but number of different
scores the downside is if we actually
measured every
single triple peptide by targeted
proteomics they don't actually correlate
that well so if you were to choose the
best ones based on our posit or you
choose these ones out here but if you
really want to measure the best
performing cut Reggie choose these three
peptides are shown in random words in
ten signals that that was definitely
shocking to us so basically we can't use
these existing repositories very well
and we can and maybe it's better off
that we measure every single peptide
since fairly straightforward 430 KD
protein like a point one but how about a
protein a little bit more complicated
like April be in April B is the main
protein in LDL low-density lipoprotein
the bad cholesterol and it's an enormous
protein it's over 500 Katie very
complicated protein it's not that easy
to deal with biochemical and where we
didn't measure every single peptide by
mass spectrometry and we compared that
again with a number of spectra that
people were getting back from GD 8 runs
and what was shocking is that the the if
you rank them and read here is shown as
the peptides based on our targeted
experiment most intense one of the least
in tens and the ones that are sampled
most frequently by Dana dependent
position are shown in purple so you
wouldn't even pick a peptide that were
in the top 100 if you were actually
measuring them entirely by using the
spectrum counts are present in different
repositories and this is so it may be
actually worth actually measuring
original I'm tied in a targeted way to
empirically determine we kept asking me
the best response so people of course
develop predictors what I use these
predictions since there's been about
iverson papers on their own predictions
the downside as all those predictions
are caused our dealt are the victors are
trained using that the same repositories
so they're very good predictor whether
you'll sample something my dating and
acquisition but not necessarily that
peptide is best measure quantitative
measure of an individual action by
target points so again if you look here
in rad here's our individual peptides
measure signal by by target / do
and if you show in blue this the
different prick tips course and you can
actually make you know scatter plot
showing basically there's no correlation
release it's a very poor correlation of
one and you could probably say well
maybe I'm cherry picking them but this
basically just matter which protein you
pick almost every protein has a similar
sort of lack of correlation between
between the prediction algorithms and
the and the actual timing pretty much
data so I'll type tell you a little bit
about how we decide you about about
doing this so so we wanted to identify
plasma proteins with altered protein
abundance and also sense a rat model who
start off with seven rats on a low salt
diet and seven that I had a high-salt
diet Lisa these seven dolls all sense of
rats end up developing severe
hypertension getting left ventricular
hypertrophy and and just part failure
and we wanted to then go through the
literature and be able to pull out
pulled out about 109 proteins that were
predicted to to be involved in in re
predictive of other hypertension
injectable I could just heart failure
heart disease inflammation etc that
could be measured in plasma and it's
like they quote of doing a Google search
prior to going in visiting foreign city
and in there we had skylines they
predict all the basic tryptic peptides
within some given rules and tell me all
the fragment ions that could be used for
that we then had skyline out put this
into a single hour set of methods of the
151 injections which were measured over
about seven days so the idea is instead
of actually going and trying to predict
what best signal for best peptides and
best fragment ions we're going to be
used for an individual protein we were
just going to impair putting this for
all of them and it just basically that
need to be done once and it only took
about seven days of interest of time
when you get through this consideration
of cost and expense and time or making a
monoclonal antibody has substantial
cheaper and faster
so let me just uh a little bit about
what happened so we did you know 109
proteins and put it on your peptides 151
injections we then we're able to detect
49 of these hundred nine proteins 135
peptides and some 180 transitions we
then cut this into a single injection
which we call scheduling so we just
measure the actual individual kept back
for a narrow period of time or our type
come down and then the ultimate eight in
the end it looks like this so we start
with under nine proteins we induct 4935
peptides this is in this heat map at
base without peptide so these are the
130 each row is the hunt 135 peptides we
could measure 135 peptides in the
fortune animal and each column isn't one
each of the 14 animals the ones on the
left are those that were from the
healthy animal for lunch on the right
were those with a just part failure or
the boss all sensitive rats that were
given a high-salt diet and these were
measured in technical triplicates so
each column is that any zero is the is
the mean of the trip injections and
there were 34 peptides of mapping back
to 13 gene products that were
statistically different between the
groups but as you can actually see I
mean from the clustering that's done
here it was very easy to differentiate
between these two groups and obviously
the difference is here now just largely
the difference between biological
organisms and if we obviously if you had
more more animals you probably be able
to find a greater percentage of these
individual objects that were successful
successfully different this isn't that
surprising these peptides aren't saying
is specific for hypertension or
congestive heart failure it's just
saying that these peptides are different
between these two conditions and so they
could actually just be saying that these
animals are sick but it's actually a
good starting point it's not surprising
that we find such a high percentage of
our total peptides that are different
between them who started with a bunch of
knowledge again based on what was in the
literature of things people I proposed
actually may be useful to differentiate
between congestive heart failure or
hypertension or inflammation or
cardiovascular disease
so what are some additional examples
that we often that we try to try to use
and so one thing we often do in our
department here is of course are any i
Norge enormous department and will often
do is I'll try to do large screams
authority I knocked down and then I can
do that they see which of these
knockdowns actually have a phenotype
because of course lots of cases where
you don't actually get knocked down on
the target protein so we want to go to
have a very rapid way which someone
could actually screen for what not a
actually neutral gene punk was actually
knocked out or not without actually
having to have an antibody because again
a lot of model systems are good
antibodies so here's just two examples
either to gene products / binding
peptides in drosophila and we developed
an essay between the two of them the
types would rather the ones that we
register screen for we were able to use
this so basically this B column right
here on the measurement of an individual
peptide that was armed is a a control so
basically the equipment like a loading
control and then the tread appear is ten
it's actually being knocked down and in
this case we're getting greater than 99
depletion send pollution on the right
hand side of the exact same samples done
by western blot we confirm that the the
target protein it was a control is it
has this very similar to what we're
getting based on the master poetry data
and the interesting thing here is that
the Western blot by ECL shows there's no
detectable amount by I see Ella the ACP
78 so it shows it but that's largely
just because the dynamic range ecls
fairly limited to about 10 but the
dynamic range of mass spectrometer we
already told told talked about was about
ten to the fourth so even though this
this peptide is knocked down my greater
than ninety-nine percent it's still
easily and readily detectable by mass
spectrometry it's just we can actually
truly measure that and knocked out by
nine tonight greater than Henderson
we do this for several other cases too
and of course just like you can have an
antibody to multiple different domains
for gene products you can measure more
different peptides to provide you
different conformation maybe different
isoforms or splice variants etc so here
we measured two different peptides this
individual gene product which provide
independent confirmation of knockdown
and again we had a different road in
control we're not limited to five
proteins here's an example showing p3
being knocked down and the results that
we get by mass spectrometry and
completely a fraction example and to
reflect very closely what we actually
get my Western bloc and we use captain H
here in this case is a little yeah just
a very simple example we have the mass
spectrometry equivalent of a Western
blot we knew this from multiple things
in parallel and we can we don't have to
make an antibody or any of you know of
any reagents the process students we
could we have lots of ways which we
check the specificity but mostly it's by
synthesizing synthetic peptides or by
actually using recombinant proteins okay
but told you fair amount of information
now about what we actually will find the
data in the axial sample we wound up for
very low abundance proteins like things
like transcription factors so if in this
case you know we would would help if we
could identify which transcription
factors we have seen before and
fragmentation figment of these peptides
but so we talked about the challenges of
using existing databases but this is
even a more extreme case person like
transcription factors because if you
consider the transcription factors that
we have encoded in the human genome and
what fractionally any data in any in any
public repositories majority of them
have known tryptic peptides are no
peptide at all have ever been seen by
the public so like something 768
transcription factors that we were
looking for trying to build assets for
more than 600 of them had no peptides
found in the in a mist spectrum library
at the time that we started doing these
experiments and then of the remaining
ones some of them
and one or two so majority evolved what
of the proteins that food would be
interested there would be no information
you need to go look for in the first
place manila depository so we decided to
kind of base our approach and how we're
going to do this was to be able to make
protein or commonly I saw a a seminar by
Josh lebar at Arizona State University
where he'd been talking about making
thousands of proteins out of protein
microarray in parallel and I mean why
don't we just do this in 96-well plates
at had a lot of communication with him
about it and it turns out you know what
we were able to do is use his cDNA
clones for making innovative individual
CD individual proteins were commonly
using an in vitro transcription
translation system that we weren't done
with Pierce and this was based on the
HeLa cell extract and all of these cDNA
clones are fused with GST so we were
able to start out with 96 but we
eventually did this for a 730 we did
individual transcription translation we
enrich for the proteins by glutathione
resin digest with proteins that we
monitored all three peptides using such
a reaction monitoring we confirm things
by silver stain gels and also by western
blot but basically the data looks like
this for an individual gene product we
now have intensities peptides we know
exactly where they loot from we know
what their which [ __ ] mascara Butte the
most what portions of the signal and in
most cases the proteins that we produce
are relatively pure there happens to be
in our extract a couple of goods i'm
lining proteins but there still are
proteins are still more than half the
target proteins that were making all the
proteins are fused to GST so we were
able to use peptides from GST to
quantify the amount of the gene product
and there's not a lot of proteins that
are actually produced but still there's
plenty in order measured by mass
spectrometry more copies assay
development all but we had a hundred
percent success rate and expressing some
130 proteins that were still several
proteins that were relatively small and
did produce good trip
so those cases even doing the target on
sa buying mass spectrometry would be
hard in the first place that is good to
actually start by knowing that as
opposed to just not knowing what you're
missing we measured some of these things
in vitro since I proteins we also
officially the nuclear extract and while
the data from the nuclear extract goes a
lot noisier and a substantial amount of
interference it may peptides loot the
same retention time at a similar
fragmentation pattern we can get a lot
of information about like the the
tissue-specific expression of individual
project like Canada to the data you know
with with them using ctcf we also see
you know it's more fun in ft 2 and and
so we get you right off the bat without
too much work we get a lot of
quantitative data where kangleon and
quantitative data between different
conditions we now know what we're
looking for we know what signals and
what data that's out of the noise
actually represent our target peptides
and we do have a lot of sensitivity we
feel pretty comfortable now we have
absolute structural specificity because
we have not only the hydrophobicity
peptide mass the peptide mass the
fragment we also note down the rank
order on the of the individual fragment
ions that provide us with a very strong
qualitative confirmation of a measure
war with England measuring so the first
applications we did for this we're done
with John's tablet analysis lab I am
very talented gratitude and Esther got
just started these experiments so
basically you wanted to know which
transcription factors separate a
separate into different discrete
chromatin compartments and so it
basically took the nucleoplasm we added
different amounts of salt and kept
taking the soluble component from there
and so basically what we're doing is
displacing different amounts of proteins
from the from the chromatin and an age
these fractions are then measured by
mass spectrometry we can make different
from heat map plots like this to measure
different transcriptional regulators and
see some of these these proteins are
alluded only an isotonic buffer some are
stable at very high salt concentration
some
we actually become an intermediate salt
concentration which indicate that one
loosely bound than those are very stable
and some only come off at a by what he
had a DNA's or an enzyme like Emma days
in order to completely chop up the DNA
into its components the histone proteins
then of course things like the nuclear
membrane even when he chopped up DNA its
dulse remains in the peloton Andrew what
to do this to even greater scale so he
extended the number of factions extended
number of proteins to more than 300
protein and he was able to get a similar
sort of pattern he mapped show basically
the chromatin segregate segregation of
these 300 transcription factors in a
very simple quick analysis he was able
to do this from multiple different cell
types and do it very very rapidly we
confirm a lot of this data by western
blots and it's pretty some exciting
results so when we started this
experiment we wanted protégée measured
was cap on isoforms and measure these
three different peptides and in general
these ties all agreed across the
different examples that we measured with
the exception of one sample I just one
sec right here that's 600 million molar
stable sample from the k562 cell line we
noticed that this this one peptide this
VL B and D a qk had a much lower
abundance than and the other two
peptides and in most cases people just
chalk this up and say that well this is
an outline or walk through a salad this
really began to bug and roo and us we
can try to track this down well we spend
a little bit more time looking at this
it turns out there's actually a third
isoform and this third ice phones not
including this extra third peptide so by
measuring different individual peptides
you can actually get different
isoform-specific type information so
these this purple and blue peptides
represent the signal from from
one two and three and the the green or
the yellow peptide representing signal
from your size 4 12 and of course this
is tissue-specific because it have g2
don't see this difference at all we
confirm this by western blot using an
antibody to the to the carboxy-terminal
and you can see here there is a small
unluckily i salaam cousin here okay so
there's still a challenge here in the
fact that these assets will take a lot
of work they take a lot of time in an
effort and stuff and what we and what we
often happen is you'd measure nastay
measuring 100 peptide 200 protein you
measure in a thousand different samples
and then you go geez know there's this
paper that came out and and in this
paper it says other proteins other
peptide is actually really important
this sample set instead he have to think
about going back and we measured all the
samples again so what we really wanted
was methodology that had a selectivity
of targeted a ceramic and Greta paid
independent acquisition so we won
something was gonna be unbiased but we
wanted to be on make it so that you
could target very specific peptides
computationally and if you need to go
back and add an individual peptide later
you won't have to go back and rerun the
experiment so basically Davis all lab is
been calling this sort of basically
digital archive of all samples and other
people via to call this is agent Lee's
so I've already talked a little bit
about the fact that there's these
alternatives as its dated pendek
position and then there's also the
selector reaction lot i guess the
parallel reaction wondering is permits
use using a slightly different type of
instrument hardware basically targets is
very narrow mass charged windows it
doesn't cover the entire mass range only
cover the selected region of the entire
master age you have this nice thing
about it is that you have this repeated
duty cycle so so you could actually
generate these extracted Iannetta grams
you set to quantify individual peptides
but the things that peptides have fallen
the in betweens in this precursor master
charge region really are a challenge
because we overlook them we don't we
don't have an
need to provide any other peptide
quantitative information for peptides
and fall and insulin is missing reduced
so there's this new did it's not too
knew it was it's about 10 years old as a
data acquisition strategy called data
independent acquisition and the idea the
concept is that we just alter the mass
range up and we fragment everything that
window and then we hope that the
fragment ions hectic masters the data
looks a little different to basically if
we take this 505 10 we get data looks
like this and so you have these
individual fragment ions and co-vary
versus time and you can actually make
plots of an individual spectrum an
8-point time and again you can slip we
could a slice lead in the other
direction and this now instead things
the mass of the peptide is the mass the
precursor I mean in which a product I'm
Dina it's very similar to what we get
with its idea we can extract the data
after the fact so if we have an
individual peptide that falls in this
individual mass window we can extract
them the fragment ions from those that
predicted from the usual targeting
peptide from within that window and you
can plot it in this sort of way here's
just plotting it in three dimensions
here's twenty two dimensions like our
sophomore dust and we can also do it for
the precursor information and the
fragment ion information both will
provide four different pros and cons to
the interpretation qualitative so one of
the challenges that we have is kind of
not appreciated this type of data is the
selectivity so if you want to measure
this individual peptide and the yeast
lysate with the only play mastered by
windows a lot of these experiments are
done more y de windows like 20 or 25
this is what the data looks like and you
wouldn't know to really say pick this
individual region of time here and say
this belongs for target peptide sort of
like doing a western blot with a very
non specific antibody we've now because
we've opened up the window the precursor
mass there's lots of things called at
mass there's lots of things i have this
sort of sort of fragmented masses within
a given range so as we open up the
window should be narrow our spectrum
looks kind of like this and now i'm
plotting with master charge and it gets
the point where as you open your window
quite why you're
peptides are actually not necessarily
the most intense peptide within the
isolation until maturity student my
students also like to say that data
dependent efficient is about balance
right so we ideally we want to have
smaller windows but in order to do that
we need to sample more frequently which
means we don't sample the commander
graphic peak very often and likewise if
you want to go to something like five
messages wide windows we would sample
the peak not very well at all it
wouldn't be able to get very big want to
get across the commander grabbing p so
one option of course is to is to make
more projections and then that increase
the increase the frequency which you
sample the peak it has high selectivity
but the downside here is that you know
how you decrease your throughput by a
factor of two because you have to make
multiple injections to crow in the
entire administration so we begin to
think about this a lot over the last
three or four years and one of the
things that was an eye over to us was
when this new instrument the cougs
active was released on the market by
thermo Fisher it has some interesting
combination hardware has a quad so we
can isolate an individual mass we could
subject it to fragments and we could
store those fragments and then we can
measure those fragments and then we'll
be trapped mass analyzer and this is
done I generally in series and the
interesting thing is that the time it
takes to fill that seat wrap it's done
in parallel with the previous
acquisition and then fill in general is
relatively short compared with the
acquisition of the mass spectrum so what
we wanted to do was to fill multiple
different disjoint windows and cut the
mixed spectrum with the intention that
we have a computational strategy allow
us to D mix or demote capacity at the
end so let me bear with me a second
while I try to describe this a little
bit so I imagine you wanted to measure
formats charged wood windows and span
from 408 you have a hundred for masters
wide windows so let's say we wanted to
randomly select five of those windows we
could take those and measure
and we can isolate them all in series we
could fragment them we could store them
in the trapper to measure one spectrum
it contains all five of a separate for
mass charge rather than those we're
going to take five of the remaining 95
that are left and do the same thing
again and we keep doing this for the
third scan etc until we get to scan 20
where there's only five windows left we
select those and then measure now this
is where it gets a little interesting
and then twenty first scan we refill the
list and start the whole process again
so we randomly selected the twenty-first
can five more scans and there's a part
that here that's pretty cool and that is
that we and that between scan 20 and 21
there's a single mass masculine oh
that's shared between the two the
remaining four ones are different
because of this if there are peaks of
fragments in the same isolation wind
that are the sim or between scan 20 and
21 they must come from the same
isolation window those are different
most company on worms so the idea here
is can we take this mixed spectrum it
contains by combinations of five
separate windows and ultimately
demultiplex them in two or five and
other visual components and I'll spare
you the linear algebra math being here
but basically yes we can here's the data
here that's that's shown measuring 20
mass charged with our data and each
individual scan here's the wealth of the
data and when you d multiplex it to the
individual for master charge when
isolation would know data is much
cleaner much easier to assign the
peptide location and the quantitative
data is much a cleaner and better signal
noise we have multiple different
examples of this here is this 10 mass
charged with gated and penetration data
here's 20 mass charged with what we call
MSX it's multiplexing data and d
multiplex the individual components and
when you blow them up you can obviously
tell the signal annoy so much better
that's a lot less interfere so again
it's like having an antibody with bench
one special activity instead of having
an antibody that has ten
man charged with the selectivity we
actually have down or master charge more
than double even though we're covering
20 master charge of the data in each
individual spectrum here's just a third
example definitely very powerful
technology and order try to make bigger
improvements in it the final kind of
catch here is that yes this also
quantitative this was something a lot of
time validating and depending on the
complexity of the mixture yeah there is
or is not more sensitive that I'm using
just data by using the more traditional
aidan an interesting one thing that was
a it's a little bit striking here is
that here is an oxidized form of the
same individual peptide when you have
ten men charged by worth of data that
oxidized oxidation is a 16 Dalton
difference it's aight mess charge the
birth of all that within the same
legislation window they have almost the
exact same magma night up to the
modifications an oxide Medina so you
can't really distinguish between it
until you get down to that form esters
isolation we know so this bottom
commander Graham is actually 20 minutes
charged with the data that deeper
complexity individual components so
there's a couple challenges here one is
the wide precursor windows fragment
molten to once we can solve this using
this MSX approach this multiplexing
approach there can be some limiting
factors and that largely due to
sensitivity and that is that it takes
longer to fill the I traffic going to do
this and also not all instruments are
really capable of doing this MSX
experiments we wanted to modify the
experiment design in order to improve
this a bit so if you had a 20 man
charged with the data and you had to
individual peptides that span that
isolation windows what we want to do is
you know you can shrink the windows down
to 10 mass of charge and cover half the
mass range and you improve the
specificity but you wouldn't you'd miss
things from 500 600 800 900 or you know
it's 200 mass charge that are outside
the window so one thing that we came up
with when I said you have is is shifting
the windows so
to kind of show this like this from now
on in and happening is you get some
peptides that that follows in the same
isolation window they would they would
look like this they were not shifting if
you shift the window those that are on
the other half the window form the
sawtooth pattern and we can ultimately d
multiplex s to the appropriate
components and just to kind of give you
a sense is that if we measure the nms
one data versus doing ten mastercharge
where the isolation which is half the
mass range or less comprehensive burst
of doing 20 men charged data st
multiplex we're almost getting the same
sort of sensitivity as the 10 master
charge data using 20 mass-to-charge
worth of data and then vball and depends
of course depending on how many fragment
ions are you actually music but
regardless when you have 20 mass charged
with the data your lower limit of
quantitation your sensitivity and your
quantitative capabilities are not
anywhere near as good as if you've
narrower windows but with the narrower
windows you have less comprehensive data
analysis and and which all we can do is
we can ship those windows and d multibus
them computationally and our software
tool skyline handles all these things
automatically in a seamless way to the
user so there is still some issues here
i made the sound fairly straightforward
we have software tools that can manage
this there is a little dirty little
secret in doing these analyses and that
is when you try to measure these things
by dated and acquisition we have a big
difference in simple things just like
Biosciences so why such a reaction
monitoring where we target individual
peptides so basically we have gaps in
our mass range but we measure it
selected peptides very sensitively I so
do transcription factors the file sizes
are treating there are only about 5 to
20 million by a file so it takes a
second field few seconds just important
data into our software tools with data
independent acquisition the file size
store anywhere from 200 megabytes so
easily a factor 10 not a factor of four
your 50 size so we're looking at minimum
30 seconds to tens
minutes to import this data and towards
opportunity so if you consider something
like fifty ones or so you pretty much
minimal quantitative experiment we want
to do we're going now from what used to
take us 10 minutes to import the data
into a software tool to ours so we began
to start thinking about ways to solve
this and we have another project that's
being done jointly between our lab at
the University of Washington Nathan
Yates's lab at the University kiss bird
info clinica and also both being done on
amazon web services we called this
course project org and basically it was
meant to be a platform for storing and
managing and sharing mass spectrometry
nado and it's based in the cloud and
there is some pros and cons of cloud
computing so one of course is the is the
masca scalable storage and compute
resources you don't need to worry about
the fact that your wedding on a disk
based all the time you just pay for more
storage amazon as you need it you can
achieve economies of scale so basically
if everybody in the entire community is
putting things in the same account the
price is costing the community we get a
benefit because Amazon Web Services of
course not charges less money to have
you know petabytes of data that we would
if we just 10 a few terabytes of data
really pay for what you use if we buy 20
terabytes of storage now today most that
storage is empty until three four five
years down the road when we finally
filled up that storage so we've been
paying a lot for dis largely empty we're
going to set access that data anywhere
in the world if you use a good cloud
computing a service I there's a lot of
redundancy and security and there's a
lot of just also improved flexibility so
let's say you've built a lot of computer
hardware in your lab and you know in a
month's time you realize you needed
machines that had more RAM random access
memory the only way to solve that
problem right would be to actually go
and order new computers with greater
amounts of RAM but if you use the cloud
you can just change the instances that
you use to using higher memories so it's
actually great
actually change directions pretty
quickly there are a lot of criticism so
forth music crowd repeating there's a
lot of ownership of the infrastructure
and tight federal funding times if
someone lost their funding and you are
leasing the computers you you then
basically now lose your computing
infrastructure when if you bought the
hardware you actually have even if there
are older computers you still have some
hardware you now get stuck with a
monthly bill it's sort of like again
LASIK versus owning a car or renting a
house versus you know purchasing a house
a lot of the software applications
require modification and one thing
that's a kind of thing that we actually
haven't found to be a big deal yet and
all the scratches a little bit is
limited data transfer rate so some
universities may actually have an issue
or institution may have an issue were
the bandwidth of the internet maybe a
maybe a bottle necking and if we're
talking about collecting data files of
about one gigabyte per hour it's not
really a challenge to upload it a
gigabyte per hour so we can upload it in
parallel with the data collection so
about 15 months ago we released this
initial course project it has a user
interface for uploading sharing and
making message from when she dated
public we now have quite a bit over
eight hundred users 11 terabytes this is
a little bit outdated we can get data
files are stored in a very unique
distributed data structure that allow us
to is it taneously access individual raw
data using is from massively parallel
computing infrastructure we have a lot
of basic chromatogram in spectrum
viewers and now and this is just showing
what it looks like you know on the right
hand side is chorus and left hand sides
what we modeled it off the google drive
and and from left hand side is basically
seeing you know individual files and
multiple people were accessing and any
improvement directories and share them
and that's basically the same thing that
we're treating mass spectrometry data is
a is it constant things you have data
stored in projects and experiments of
that project
and you can visualize them analyze them
etc build viewers be going to the mass
spectrometry data and you can also
analyze it this is this will be
available starting the next month's go
to doing things like database searching
like I mentioned that the technology
called seaquest it on a cloud I get some
parameters and kickoff analyses you can
visualize the results and proteins
individual peptide your data and you can
start to look at quantitative analysis
etc comparisons between option lunch we
can align chromatograms etc in for
calculate statistics what used to take
hours of computer time now has done in a
matter of minutes okay I mentioned
earlier that one of the challenges that
they'd independent acquisition and the
dirty little secret is just that keep so
long to attract the data on these files
so what we wanted to do is to be able to
store all the data in course so if
someone didn't have to carry around a
terribly under hard drive I mean on your
laptop imagine but a lot of laptop hard
drives aren't that big to begin with and
a lot of laptops are actually pretty
funky too so we want to basically the
client to be able to make requests for
commander grams the cloud and chorus to
return this and we weren't sure how fast
this could be i have a quick sort of
video to kind of illustrate this so here
we are looking at a laptop it's a fairly
fast laptops and i7 taking ram with SSD
we have a local disk versus that on the
cloud and if you were to copy these
things from the internet about 15
gigabytes of data that's stored you know
remotely this of course isn't simple to
be able to download end up taking on our
hat downloading full and so if we import
it locally from the local disk now that
we downloaded it an hour and a half
there's importing six different files
into Scotland from the local SSD and
we're limited now by the hard disk CPU
infrastructure their laptop our verses
from the cloud so we're going to import
the results from from the cloud we can
now browse the cloud just like you can
versus using Google Docs or Google Drive
or Dropbox you can browse the directory
structure remotely we can import those
six miles from route leading across the
internet and you'll see that because of
the way we store and manage data on the
internet on the left hand side is Athena
being imported one of six files has
already been uploaded it's the software
through the internet with very little
bandwidth problems on the right hand
side with local reading and locally from
disk which would expect would be much
faster because there's no swaddling of
course the internet of court and so what
we found is that because the data
structure that we can store the data in
and that we can have multiple CPUs
reading the data in parallel we can in a
sense this dream the data liquid down to
the computer it's much faster to read it
remotely across the internet and it is
to read it locally on an SSD dryer so
now basically all six of the files have
been loaded into the file on the left
hand side we're still only loaded one
data file from disk and now you can go
and start already looking at the data
from the cloud you can start to look at
all the individual components you start
to analyze the data you can look at
spectrum which again it brings it from
the internet it's extremely fast very
low latency and reading it through
processor this is something that's to go
okay little bit conclusions so I really
think targeted proteomics is going to be
a major growing area of pro humans are
the idea of a forming mass spec
equivalent of a Western blot is really
powerful modern hardware and novel data
actonel strategy i'll begin to make an
acquisition a realistic solution well
digital penetration is existed for a
decade it really hasn't become feasible
or practical and pulling the last like
three or four years method setup is much
simpler for data independent acquisition
although the downside is that the data
file sizes are huge if you don't
actually need the data for the other
peptides is probably still better to use
traditional targeted measurement we're
big limited only the peptides up have
seen previously is not only impractical
but won't you started for you access
full potential so we're advocating that
you don't use things like color
repository to target those individual
peptides they actually make the Baptizer
commonly build acid very specifically to
individual proteins etc how do you think
that the future of proteomics will
require that our data we need to be
stored in the cloud and access remotely
and those features are coming in January
but a lot of people have got that a lot
of work in this so a lot of on target
pretty much work now and be done by Jim
Bollinger a lot of our independent
fishing paint on my charity eggertsen
Andrews Johnson and some yu ting but in
mclean and Nick Holman are software
engineers that meet around these tools
possible and pass and robust and all the
course development is being done by
not-for-profit Lisa called trash
Biosciences and a lot of the the
quantitative acids were building are
being done with consultation
collaboration with an evil thing go flat
and Clark Henderson did his lab we want
to make sure ultimately that the quantum
information could actually be
transferred to the clinic down the road
I'm just because there's a of course of
huge be fun and thank you very much son
happy to answer any questions
so it's currently aren't any questions
at this point I'm happy to answer any I
have some there's a lot of information
covered in a short period of time so
thank you very much for attending I
really appreciate the opportunity to go
to tell us to tell you a little bit
about things we're trying to work on and
I hope I was able to to tell you a
little bit about the challenges and also
the strength [ __ ] previewing thanks